لكنك تقول بانه اقتصاديا على المستوى
الاقتصادي روسيا لم تتاثر اطلاقا بالعقبات
والحرب بالعكس تحسن وضعها
كلا لا استطيع ان اقول ذلك
لانها ليست الصوره واحده الاقتصاد الروسي
باكمله اولا تذكر بان هيكليه الاقتصاد
الروسي
تختلف كثيرا عن ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابقه ما اقصدهم بان قطاعات الدوله او
الدوله بنفسها تهيمن على الاقتصاد اكثر من
ثلاثيا الناتج المحلي الاجمالي تحت سيطره
الدوله بشكل او باخر وهكذا كان الدوله
تمكنت من المحافظه على النمو العام من
خلال دخل الاموال الى قطاعات الدوله ولكن
اذا نظرنا خارج هذه الصوره مثلا صنعت
السيارات وقطاع الاستهلاكي او التكنولوجيا
او القطاعات الجديده
فمساله الضعف كانت شديده مثلا
صنع سيارات تنخفضت بنسبه 40% في العام
الماضي وحتى مبيعات الاستهلاكيه والمفرق
انخفضت بعشره بالمئه فهي ليست صوره موحده
للاقتصاد باكمله بل ان هيكليه الاقتصاد
الروسي
[موسيقى]
خلال الازمات تتمكن فيها الحكومه بكل
سهوله من تحقيق الاستقرار على ارقام
رئيسيه ولكن هنالك يتنوعات كثيره غير ذلك
عبر القطاعات المختلفه كما ذكرنا من
الاقتصاد وهذا مشاهدناه في العام الماضي
وكذلك كما شاهدناه قبل عامين خلال جائحه
كوفيد 19 بعض القطاعات كان دعوها بكثير
ولكن الارقام العامه كانت افضل بكثير بسبب
دعم الحكومه لكن كما تعرف الكرملين توقف
اصلا عن نشر البيانات الاقتصاديه بعد وقت
قصير من بادئ التوغل العسكري في اوكرانيا
على ماذا بنيت هذه الخلاصات
نعم توقفوا عن اصدار البيانات او فيما يخص
المعلومات الحساسه فمثلا لاحصل على الكثير
المعلومات فيما خصم باقات الموازنات او
الحوالات الماليه واين الاموال مثلا لانهم
لا يريدون لهذه المسائل انها تكون معرضه
لعقوبه جديده قضينا وقتا طويلا لمراجعه كل
المعلومات التي يمكننا مراجعتها فمثلا من
جهه بيانات التجاره ليس من السيء مراجعه
هذه البيانات لان البيانات التجاره نحصل
عليها من الدول العميله مثلا الهند والصين
والامارات العربيه المتحده وتركيا وغيرها
فيكون لدينا اطباء جيد عن الارقام الروسيه
انها صحيحه او لا وبالفعل كانت صحيحه لان
استطيع ان نراجع حساباته والارقام من دول
اخرى